draw a circle and label the radius
diameter Center and circumference let me
draw a circle and it won't be that well
drawn of a circle but I think you get
the idea so that is my circle I'm going
to label the center over here so I'll do
the center I'll call it C so that is my
center and I'll draw an arrow there that
is the center of the circle and actually
the circle itself is the set of all
points that are a fixed distance away
from that Center and that fixed distance
away that they're all from that center
that is the radius so let me draw the
radius so this distance right over here
is the radius that is the radius and
that's going to be the same as this
distance which is the same as that
distance I can draw multiple radii all
of these are radii the distance between
the center and any point on the circle
now a diameter just goes straight across
the circle going through the center from
one side of the circle to the other side
going through the center and it's
essentially two radii put together so
for example this would be a diameter
that would be a diameter you have one
radii then another radii all one line
going from one side of the circle to the
other going through the center so that
is a diameter that is a diameter and I
could have drawn it other ways I could
have drawn it like this that would be
another diameter but they're going to
have the exact same length and then
finally we have to think about the
circumference and the circumference is
really just how far you have to go to go
around the circle or if you put a string
on this circle how long would that
string have to be so what I'm tracing
out in blue right now the length of what
I'm tracing out is the circumference so
right over here that is the
circumference circumference
circumference and we're done